The big political story over the last 24 hours,
Bernie Sanders has suspended his 2020 Democratic
presidential campaign.
There's just so much to talk about. And I've
received hundreds of messages since yesterday
about this. Emails, tweets, all sorts of other
messages, Instagram. And so I want to go through
this in sections. I want to make sure we cover
everything. I want to make sure we sort of
turn over every stone that needs to be turned
over in thinking about this and and going
forward. And so we're going to talk about
Bernie's decision itself and whether it made
sense. We'll talk about what exactly happened
in the campaign that at one point seemed to
be going so well. We'll talk about what this
means for the progressive movement and for
the future of who the individuals are that
may be leading. That movement will talk eventually.
We also have to talk about what this means
for November of 2020.
So we're going to get to all of those things
now. My concerns from the messages I've received
are centered around, I guess generally that
a lot of these different issues I mentioned
are being mixed up. For example, there are
people mixing up questions about the future
of the movement with November of 2020 when
there is overlap, but really there are different
decisions and different considerations to
be made there.
And it's leading to some unclear thinking
and people that I think are are not thinking
in the clearest terms about this. And I want
to make sure that if if nothing else, we can
disagree about where we end up. But let's
make sure we have all of the facts and that
we're thinking clearly and discretely about
all of these issues. If we come to different
conclusions, that's fine. I have no problem.
We're adults. But let's think through the
different elements of this. First of all,
here is Bernie himself saying yesterday that
he is suspending his campaign.
I wish I could give you better news, but I
think you know the truth, and that is that
we are now some 300 delegates behind Vise
President Biden, and the path toward victory
is virtually impossible. So while we are winning
the ideological battle and while we are winning
the support of so many young people and working
people throughout the country, I have concluded
that this battle for the Democratic nomination
will not be successful. And so today I'm announcing
the suspension of my campaign.
So, first of all, was this the correct decision
for Bernie Sanders to make? The answer is
yes. Now, Bernie talks about the math and
he realizes, he says, that he has no path
to the nomination. It's important to understand
that it's been weeks since the numbers changed.
So if the numbers yesterday show no path to
the nomination, he also had no path. Weeks
ago when we outlined that and still many people
were reacting very emotionally and sort of
resisting that. After Super Tuesday, Bernie's
shot was diminished to about a 1 percent shot
after the March 10th states voted. He had
about a point, five percent chance after March
17th. It was smaller than a 0.1 percent chance.
And that has not since changed. So Bernie's
decision is the right one. Bernie's decision
is backed by the math, and there's no question
about that whatsoever. Remember, even after
it was just Biden versus Bernie and everyone
else was out. Biden kept building bigger and
bigger leads in the polls. There was the idea
that coronavirus would turn it around and
reinvigorate Bernie's campaign in the polls.
Biden kept pulling away. So that's that. I
don't really think there's that much more
to say about it, particularly because Bernie
has suspended his campaign. Next question
is about the timing, Bernie getting out yesterday,
April 8th, as opposed to earlier as opposed
to later. I don't know that this is the most
important issue, but I'm not so sure about
the timing. I mean, to me, again, the numbers
haven't changed for three weeks. So in a sense,
it might have made more sense to get out three
weeks ago when we were not in the middle of
the peak of a hundred year pandemic, where
this is likely to get it be a story that gets
24 to 36 hours of attention, and then the
attention is going to be greatly diminished
waiting. I mean, listen, if you've waited
this long, maybe you just keep waiting with
no other primaries that are voting in person
in the immediate maybe you keep waiting with
the idea that when the virus starts to settle
down in the news as hopefully it will in the
next month, although we don't know, maybe
there's an opportunity for Bernie to get more
attention with this, get some concessions
or something with Joe Biden, that will be
a show of both unity and maybe also some policy
concessions that Joe Biden. I don't know.
I'm thinking out loud here, but I don't think
this is really the most important thing. Might.
Instinct is that this is acutely a time because
we are, you know, two thousand people a day
in the US or dying right now because of the
Corona virus. This maybe is not the best time
to get the most attention for what you're
doing and maybe spend the political capital
you've built in the most effective way. But
I don't think it's the most important thing
to be talking about. Could maybe, Bernie,
get something out of this in the future? Because
remember, Bernie is suspending. You can still
vote for him in upcoming primaries. He will
continue to accumulate delegates. And at some
point in the future, we imagine before or
at the convention, the convention maybe in
person, it may be digital. We just don't know
right now because of the virus. Maybe there
is some show made out of Bernie turning over
his delegates, directing his delegates, releasing
his delegates and sending them to Biden in
exchange for something that may still happen.
I don't know that we need to armchair quarterback
that, too, too much. Now let's move on to
a bigger issue. What about the meaning of
this for the progressive movement and the
understanding of why Bernie lost, which if
we don't learn anything from this, it's been
a waste. If if we don't learn anything from
this, the same things are going to keep happening
now. A lot of this analysis I've done before,
because we've already done our postmortem
on the Bernie campaign mathematically in the
last three weeks, nothing changed. And Bernie,
accepting that the math has no path to his
nomination. The math was the same three weeks
ago. So we did most of our postmortem three
weeks ago. I won't go crazy spending time
on that. But the key points to hit. Just so
we're all kind of up to speed. First of all,
the Democratic primary electorate is not as
progressive as the Internet. Read it. Twitter.
Progressive movement might make us think that
it is. This is just a reality. We talked about
this a few weeks ago. There are a lot of Democratic
primary voters who just aren't participating
in those online forums. So we don't see them.
We come away thinking that what we see on
Reddit and Twitter is far more representative
of the Democratic primary electorate than
it actually is. We sometimes are swayed by
Bernie's large rallies. Just because people
are able to gather larger rallies doesn't
necessarily mean they're going to gather more
voters when it actually becomes time to vote.
Now, you will hear on Twitter in response
to this. You're wrong, David. Everybody wants
Medicare for all. Everybody wants free college.
People were confused or tricked or bamboozled
into voting for Biden because of these wrong
calculations about electability. People are
wrong. The theme on line is in the online
left. It's Bernie is the guy with the popular
policies. But people wrongly thought Biden
was more electable, so they voted for Biden.
That's not really true. And if you look at
more detailed polls, you know, it's very easy
to say everybody loves Medicare for all, but
somehow they voted for Biden. You know, it's
not completely true. And this is something
if we don't accept, if we don't realize it,
we're not going to fix the problems. If you
look at data from the Kaiser Family Foundation,
it's pretty clear. I want a disclaimer. Kaiser
Family Foundation has nothing to do with Kaiser
Permanente, the insurance company. Sometimes
when I mentioned the K F F people say, David,
you're touting industry talking points. No,
the Kaiser Family Foundation. You can look
up, Google it. It's widely documented. It
shares the word Kaiser. It has nothing to
do with the insurance company Kaiser Permanente.
They're an independent research agency. And
the point is, the more you tell people about
Medicare for all and how it would actually
work, the lower support is. Now, this doesn't
mean Medicare for all is good or bad. I'm
talking about the political viability. We
have some of the data on the screen. This
is not anything about my opinion. It is simply
me reminding you the numbers are more complex
than simply saying everybody loves Medicare
for all. But somehow Biden won by two and
a half million votes. The more you tell people
about the specifics of how Medicare for all
would work, the more divided opinion is. It's
not overwhelmingly against Medicare for all,
but opinion about Medicare for all is split
very evenly as people learn more about the
specifics. So it's not overwhelming support
number two, policy aside. Not enough people
liked Bernie enough to vote for him. This
is not the Hillary stuff. Nobody likes Bernie.
That was referring to members of Congress
in the Senate. What I'm talking about is there
are lots of people who I'm sure find Bernie's
policies fine, but they didn't like him or
his campaign enough to get them over the hump,
casting a ballot for Bernie Sanders. Now,
there are all of these hot takes that Bernie
lost because voters were confused about issues
vs. electability. But a lot of people just
didn't like Bernie enough to vote for him.
It's just the reality. OK, I don't take it.
Personally, it has nothing to do with the
viability of the policies either. Number three,
I've already talked about the toxic people
around Bernie. There are lots of them. This
isn't about mean people on Twitter. That's
not what I'm talking about. I'm talking about
campaign surrogates. It wouldn't be particularly
particularly decorous for me to start naming
them. Is it decorous or de chorus for me to
start naming them down? Now it's over. But
there are lots of people around, Bernie, that
were repellent to many, many voters. It was
a bad calculation. What can you do? OK, we
learned. And lastly, Bernie was not helped
by some of the optics around his campaign.
The Democratic Socialist label didn't help.
I said this five years ago and there are now
more and more leftist folks who are coming
around to this. It just didn't help thinking
about it. It's not anything personal, personal,
personal. About Bernie necessarily. But the
Dems socialist language, the language of revolution.
Most Democrats don't want revolution. They
want to fix the system. And even, you know,
this is so minor. But like when Bernie praised
Cuba's literacy program and then doubled down
on it. I get it. Just because Cuba did something
doesn't mean that Fidel Castro is good, but
it just didn't help, Bernie. None of this
stuff helped Bernie Sanders. All together,
many factors. So then we get to does this
say anything about the future of the progressive
movement more broadly? I think the answer
is not necessarily. It depends on the choices
that we make. I've said before the movement
to succeed is going to be a need to be led
by someone who shares Bernie's fundamental
values, but has better optics, better framing,
better language and a less toxic supporting
cast around them. There's plenty of time to
figure that out. We want to take too much
time because we want to make progress and
win. But there's plenty of time to figure
that out. But in the immediate, in the midst
of 100 year pandemic during which the president
we have is an incompetent, weaponized buffoon,
we've got to deal with the general election.
This is not trivial. This is not academic.
And this is where the black white hot takes
are just exploding on the Internet, probably
to the detriment of the movement. Bigger picture
because everybody is claiming to have the
perspective that informs what every Bernie
supporter should do in November. You've got
the never Biden people. You've got the Bernie
or bust people, which are not necessarily
the same as the never Biden people. You have
the reluctant sort of trumps better than Biden.
But I hate him anyway. People. Here's my suggestion.
Let's stop. Let's be adults here. And I'll
explain to you what I mean by that. Bernie,
supporters have a limited number of options.
It's not there's not an unlimited number of
paths forward. And those are you vote for
Biden. You vote for Trump. You don't vote
at all. You write, Bernie in talking in November.
Now you write someone else in or you vote
for a third party candidate. These are all
different actions. But in practical terms,
any of these actions other than voting Biden
is an action that gets Trump one vote closer
to reelection. That's not a value judgment.
I'm not saying it's good or bad. We'll get
to the values in a moment. But any decision
other than a vote for Biden is a vote or a
non vote that helps Donald Trump. Now, you
know, in blue states where Biden will win,
maybe in practice it matters less what you
do in terms of helping Trump. But at the national
level, all choices other than voting Biden
are a vote that helps Trump get closer to
reelection. Now, people may have different
reasons for choosing these options. So as
an example, you might be a Bernie supporter
and you might choose to vote for Trump because
you actually preferred Trump to Biden. Like
on policy, I guess it's conceivable you could
look at the policy and you could look at everything
about them, the people around them, cabinets
that they would. Okay. And you say, I prefer
Trump to Biden. That's one reason someone
might vote for Trump over Biden. You might
be a Bernie supporter and you might vote for
Trump because you see Trump's reelection as
acceleration ist compared to a Biden win.
And now acceleration ism is the idea that
you should accelerate capitalism because it
will speed up its eventual failure, which
will bring about the destruction of capitalism.
That's an idea you might choose. Any of these
options other than voting Biden because you
want to teach the DNC a lesson and you see
not voting for Biden as teaching the D and
see a lesson that, you know, your vote is
not a blank check. So here's where I come
down on this. I cannot in good conscience
take any action that will make Trump's reelection
more likely. It's very simple for me. I believe
that Trump is that bad. I believe the Corona
virus epidemic has been sort of. The straw
that broke the camel's back or the cherry
on top or whatever metaphor you want to use
that proves beyond any doubt how weaponized
Trump's ignorance and personality disorders
and bad ideas and cast of supporters and staffers
are. This is not vote blue no matter who for
me. I have a video about this on YouTube you
can check out. I've looked at the options
and I am choosing Biden over Trump because
he's better. OK. Yesterday on Twitter, our
friend Kyle Kolinsky responded to journalist
medi- Hassans tweet about the lesser of two
evils. And Kyle said, OK, white nationalist
Richard Spencer versus white nationalist David
Duke, who y'all got? And I responded, half
joking, but half serious, I guess. David Duke,
he seems more frail and his supporters aren't
as good at using the Internet to spread their
white nationalism. The point here is I believe
in harm reduction. I reject the idea that
acceleration ism will succeed at toppling
the system. When you look at history, you
see that the big progressive advances, which
were, you know, in the last hundred and so
years, the 1910 to 1920 progressive era, the
New Deal era and the civil rights era, those
were not revolution. Break the system and
build it back up, burn it down and start over.
Those were advances working within the system
and improving the system. Now, there is another
group that is talking about, you know, Biden
needs to earn my vote. The DNC needs to earn
my vote. They need to come and get me. And
unless they come and get me, unless they make
overtures and come and get me, they don't
deserve my vote. Another debate is, is it
Bernie? Who needs to convince his supporters
to vote for Biden? Or is it Biden who needs
to convince Bernie's supporters to vote for
Biden? This entire thing is childish to me.
This idea of who comes and gets me specifically
strikes me as both childish and completely
irrelevant. I don't care about these people
as people. I don't DFI politicians. I've expressed
before, you know, that the deification of
Bernie or Tulsi or Andrew Gang or Trump, it's
all cultish. And I just don't think these
are people that should be deified or revered
in this way. They're just people. They're
just people. They're flawed people. I don't
agree with everything in their platforms,
period. I don't care about the cult of personality
around them. I don't care about them coming
to get my vote. I'm not signing a blank check.
I look at policy and Biden is better. I'm
not arrogant enough to say Biden's gotta come
get my vote. I've looked at Biden versus Trump
on health care. Biden's better. Biden the
best. No. Biden's better. I've looked at Biden
versus Trump on taxes. Biden's better. I've
looked at Biden versus Trump on selecting
judges. Biden is better. I've looked at them
on the environment. I've looked at them on
diplomacy. I've looked at just about every
issue. And Biden is better. I'm a big boy.
I don't need Biden to come kowtow to me or
do anything like that to get my votes. I've
done the analysis on my own, and I know what
the right decision is here. I'm not going
to attack people who are going to go a different
path than I'm going. I can only control what
I do and communicate it to you and everybody's
gonna make their own decisions. I'm not going
to do ad hominems of people choosing a different
path than me or anything like that. Trump
gets another four years. I'll do what I can
to minimize the damage. If Biden wins and
defeats Donald Trump, it will be a very important
victory for the United States, and it'll be
an underwhelming, milquetoast left for a presidency
which I will work my ass off to ensure is
as progressive as possible by pushing Biden.
Everybody's got to decide for themselves.
Are you okay with your actions helping Trump
get reelected? Maybe the answer is yes. I
don't think you're a bad person. I just think
you're wrong. For me, the answer is no.
So I'm very confident in the action that I
have to take. And it's voting for Biden over
Trump. Let me know your thoughts. I'm ready.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman. We will take
a break and be back right after this.